THEY DON'T GO NEAR IT.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH
US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW
AUTHOR OF THE UPCOMING BOOK
"SILENT NO MORE" AND JEROME
CORSI WITH US.
YOU SAID I'M NOT TAKING THE
PLEA DEAL.
I KNOW I COULD GO TO JAIL FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE.
A LOT OF HE SOLVES AROUND THE
TEXT MESSAGE SENT TO YOU BY
ROGER WHO YOU JUST HEARD THAT
YOU DIDN'T REMEMBER.
YOU WERE AMENING THE TESTIMONY
NUMEROUS TIMES BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T REMEMBER WHAT YOU WROTE
OR SAID TWO YEARS AGO.
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
WHAT THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IS
ASKING ME TO DO IS ACCEPT A
FRAUDULENT PLEA WHICH I'LL
HAVE MY ATTORNEYS FILE
CRIMINAL CHARGES ON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
MY EXPERIENCE MADE IT CLEAR TO
ME THAT THE POLITICAL
CRIMINALS ARE RUNNING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
MUELLER'S PROSECUTION.
I WAS RIDICULED.
MY TESTIMONY WAS LAUGHED AT.
THEY YAWNED AT IT.
THEY MISBEHAVED AND THEY
ACCUSED ME OF BEING A LIAR AND
FABRICATOR.
AN ATTACK ON ME FOR THE BOOKS
I HAVE WRITTEN THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL 20. -- SUCCESSFUL.
20 BOOKS SINCE 2004.
>> Sean: YOU SPENT HOW MANY
HOURS BEFORE MUELLER AND HIS
TEAM?
>> I WAS THERE FOR 40 HOURS
APPROXIMATELY.
>> Sean: WHEN THEY ASKED YOU
THE PLEA DEAL WHICH THEY SAID
MIGHT RESULT IN PRO BASE --
PROBATION AND MAYBE NO JAIL
TIME AT ALL.
WHEN YOU WERE CONFRONTED WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY, YOU ARE
RIGHT, YOU ARE 72 YEARS OLD.
THIS COULD BE A LIFE STENSE
FOR -- LIFE SENTENCE IN JAIL.
WHEN THEY WERE TALKING TO YOU,
WERE THEY TELLING YOU IN YOUR
OPINION WHAT THEY WANTED TO
HEAR AND IF YOU SAID IT, YOU'D
GET OFF SCOT-FREE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IN FACT MY ATTORNEY SAID ALL
THEY WANT YOU TO SAY IS --
>> GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE.
WHAT WERE THEY TELLING YOU
THEY WANTED TO HEAR.
>> THEY WANTED TO HEAR I HAD A
SOURCE CONNECTED TO ASSANGE OR
I IN SOME WAY HAD A DIRECT
CONTACT WITH ASSANGE SO THEY
COULD DO THE CONNECTION.
WHICH WOULD GO ROGER STONE,
JERRY CORSI, ASSANGE.
THEN THEY HAD A BASIS FOR
COLLUSION.
IT WAS COMPLETE NONSENSE.
THEY WOULDN'T ACCEPT WHEN I
TOLD THEM THAT I NEVER MET
ASSANGE AND I HAD NO CONTACT
WITH ASSANGE OR INTERMEDIARY.
>> Sean: YOU NEVER HAD ANY
CONTACT WITH JULIAN ASSANGE OR
WIKILEAKS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Sean: NEVER?
>> NEVER.
>> Sean: JEROME CORSI
DECIDED TO TURN DOWN A PLEA
DEAL AGREEMENT WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE AND
HE SAYS HE COMMITTED NO CRIME.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU NEVER SPOKE TO JULIAN
ASSANGE.
YOU NEVER MET HIM.
YOU NEVER SPOKE TO ANYONE AT
WIKILEAKS, ANY SURROGATE?
>> THAT IS THE CORRECT.
I NEVER DID.
>> Sean: OKAY.
LET ME GO BACK TO AUGUST 2,
2016.
WORD A FRIEND AND EMBASSY PLAN
TWO MORE DUMPS REFERRING TO
WIKILEAKS AND JULIAN ASSANGE.
ONE BACK AND THE SECOND IN
OCTOBER.
IMPACT PLAN TO BE DAMAGING.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW HIM, HOW DID
YOU KNOW THAT?
>> ANALYSIS.
I HAD INFORMATION ON HOW THE
DEMOCRATS PUT THE COMPUTER
SYSTEM TOGETHER.
THE RELEASE OF INFORMATION ON
JULY 22, 2016.
THEY GOT DEBBIE WASSERMAN
SCHULTZ, TAKEN FROM THE D.N.C.
E-MAIL SERVER.
BUT ONLY INCLUDED OFFICIALS
WHO WERE NOT THERE.
JOHN PODESTA WAS MISSING.
SO WHOEVER STOLE THE E-MAIL
HAD JOHN PODESTA.
I SAID IF I HAD PODESTA'S
E-MAIL I WOULD KEEP THEM UNTIL
THE END AND MAKE IT MY OCTOBER
SURPRISE.
>> Sean: DEDUCED THEY HAD TO
HAVE THEM BECAUSE OF THE SAME
SERVER.
>> SAME SERVER.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" THEN.
YOU SAID, "WHAT I CONSTRUCT
AND WHAT I TESTIFY TO THE
GRAND JURY IS I BELIEVED I WAS
CREATING A COVER STORY FOR
ROGER," MEANING ROGER STONE
"BECAUSE ROGER WANTED TO
EXPLAIN A TWEET I EARLIER
ASKED HIM ABOUT."
BY THE WAY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
KNEW THIS.
THEY CAN TELL VIRTUALLY MY KEY
STROKES ON THAT COMPUTER.
ROGER SAID THAT IS NOT LOGICAL
AND SAID YOU WERE SQUEEZED BY
MUELLER PROSECUTORS WHEN YOU
SAID THAT.
CAN YOU SHED LIGHT ON THAT?
>> TWO POINTS QUICKLY.
FIRST OF ALL, CONSTANTLY
PRESSED ME ABOUT WHAT ROGER
THOUGHT.
I SAID IT WAS A SHAME THAT I
DIDN'T TAKE A MIND READING
COURSE AT HARVARD BUT I CAN'T
TELL YOU WHAT SOMEBODY ELSE IS
THINKING.
LISTENING TO ROGER TONIGHT, IT
SOUNDS LIKE THAT IS ROGER'S
EXPLANATION.
>> WERE YOU TRYING TO CREATE
COVER STORY FOR RODGEER?
>> IN POLITICS AND PUBLIC
RELATIONS -- I WAS TRAINED IN
PUBLIC RELATIONS BY THE
FOUNDER OF IT, YOU CREATE
NARRATIVE TO BENEFIT YOUR
CLIENT.
BRITISH PETROLEUM GOING AFTER
THE OIL RESERVES ALL OVER THE
WORLD BECOMES B.P.
SUDDENLY IT'S BEYOND
PETROLEUM.
WELL B.P. IS NO MORE BEYOND
OIL THAN LONG JOHN SILVER
BEYOND LOOTING.
IS THAT A LIE?
>> Sean: YOU SAID THE
FOLLOWING.
"IN MY HEART I WENT INTO TELL
THE TRUTH.
I TOLD THE TRUTH AND I WON'T
SWEAR BEFORE GOD AND A JUDGE
SOMETHING I CONSIDER TO BE A
LIE.
THESE ARE E-MAILS THAT ARE TWO
YEARS OLD.
YOU ACKNOWLEDGED THE TIME YOU
HAD FORGOTTEN SOME OF THE
E-MAILS.
YOU COULD HAVE GOTTEN NO
E-MAIL AND NOW YOU ARE RISKING
DYING IN JAIL.
YOU ARE 72 YEARS OLD AND
SOMETHING WE ALL WORRY ABOUT
IN OUR LIVES.
>> YES.
>> Sean: WHY?
HERE IS MY BIGGER QUESTION.
WHAT DID YOU KNOW THEY WERE
TRYING TO GET YOU TO SAY.
WHAT DID THEY WANT?
>> THEY WANTED ME TO NAME A
SOURCE WITH WIKILEAKS THAT I
HAD THAT TOLD ME ASSANGE HAD
E-MAIL.
THE PLEA DEAL, I HAD TO GO
BEFORE A FEDERAL JUDGE AND
SWEAR UNDER GOD TO A FEDERAL
JUDGE THAT I KNOWINGLY AND
WILLFULLY SUBMITTED FALSE
INFORMATION I KNEW TO BE FALSE
TO THE FEDERAL AUTHORITIES TO
MISLEAD THEM.
I DIDN'T DO THAT.
I WILL SPEND THE REST OF MY
LIFE IN JAIL BUT I WON'T SWEAR
TO A LIE UNDER GOD.
I WON'T DO IT.
>> Sean: LISTEN, I CAN'T
TELL YOU WHO WAS ON MY SHOW
LAST WEEK.
IF I'M NO THE SAME POSITION
UNLESS I REVIEWED ALL MY
E-MAILS AND WENT BACK TO LOOK
AT IT AHEAD OF TIME, I
WOULDN'T REMEMBER.
I DON'T KNOW WHO WAS ON THE
SHOW LAST WEEK.
I CAN TELL YOU REAGAN
ACCOMPLISHMENT FROM THE
1980s BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU
WHO WAS ON.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
I THINK THIS IS VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT.
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE ANY
COMMUNICATIONS AND YOU DIDN'T
KNOW.
DID YOU EVER BECAUSE, LOOKING
FOR OP RESEARCH ISN'T A CRIME.
WE'LL GET TO OUR ATTORNEYS
NEXT.
IF YOU CONSPIRED TO STEAL,
HACK INTO SOMEBODY'S PERSONAL
E-MAILS OR WHATEVER OR HAD ANY
DOINGS WITH THAT, THAT WOULD
BE A CRIME.
DID YOU DO ANY OF THOSE
THINGS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I DEDUCED THAT ASSANGE HAD
PODESTA'S E-MAILS, I KNEW HOW
DAMAGING THEY WOULD BE AND HOW
THEY WERE USED.
I'M NOT A HUMAN TAPE RECORDER.
YOU CAN'T PUNCH A BUTTON AND
HAVE ME RECITE WORD FOR WORD A
CONVERSATION OR E-MAIL I DID
TWO YEARS AGO.
THAT IS WHAT THE PROSECUTORS
DEMANDED.
THEY RIDICULED ME.
THEY YAWNED.
THEY GOT UP IN THE ROOM.
THEY ABUSED ME ALL KIND OF
WAYS PSYCHOLOGICALLY.
THEY DID IT TO COERCE ME.
TO MAKE ME FOR ONE, TO THINK
IF I DIDN'T TELL THEM WHAT I
I -- THEY WANTED TO HEAR I'D
GO TO PRISON AND DIE THERE.
>> Sean: DID THEY SAY THAT?
>> THEY MADE IT CLEAR THESE
WERE SERIOUS OFFENSES AND
MULTIPLE CHARGES.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN YOU WROTE
THE BOOK ON JOHN KERRY.
WE HAD YOU ON MANY TIMES AT
THE TIME.
>> YES.
>> Sean: I'M READING WHAT
THE MEDIA WRITES ABOUT YOU,
THAT YOU DIDN'T BELIEVE THE
MOON LANDING WAS REAL OR THAT
9/11 -- I WANT TO GET IT
ACCURATE -- WAS AN INSIDE JOB.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU BELIEVE
THOSE THINGS OR NOT.
DO YOU?
I WAS SURPRISED WHEN I READ
IT.
>> I DON'T.
THAT IS FABRICATION.
YOU ARE GETTING INTO AN
IMPORTANT POINT.
AIRPLANE ZALINSKI ONE OF THE
PROSECUTORS RIDICULED ME AND
SAID YOU TAKE THAT FACT AND
YOU MAKE LIES.
HE IS RIDICULING MY WORK ON
BARACK OBAMA, THE BIT
CERTIFICATE OR THE -- BIRTH
CERTIFICATE BUT I'M PERSECUTED
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GET RID
OF ME.
>> Sean: YOU ARE ALLOWED TO
HAVE CONTROVERSIAL VIEWS AND
I'D DISAGREE ON BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS BUT THAT IS NOT AT THE
ISSUE HERE.
THE ISSUE IS WERE YOU OFFERED
FREEDOM IF YOU TOLD LIES?
YOU ARE TELLING YOU THEY
WANTED YOU TO LIE AND PUSHING
YOU TO LIE.
>> YES.
IF I HAD GIVEN THEM WHAT THEY
WANTED IT WOULD BE HAPPY,
HAPPY.
IN FACT, AFTER THE FIRST GRAND
JURY TESTIMONY, THEY ALL SHOOK
MY HAND AND CONGRATULATED ME
BUT BLEW IT UP IN THE SECOND
ROUND BECAUSE I DID NOT HAVE A